Senator Bill Nelson is concerned about
the child internment camps that are
increasingly being used and set up by
the current administration he's a
senator representing the state of
Florida he is a Democrat and yesterday
he tried to go to one of these
internment camps in Florida to see for
himself what the living conditions were
he wasn't allowed he was denied access
not allowed in and the camp he went to
along with Florida Democratic
congresswoman debbie Wasserman Schultz
is homestead temporary shelter for
unaccompanied children it's another one
of these outsourced contractor run
detention centers and Nelson is now
accusing the Trump administration of a
deliberate effort to cover up the
conditions bill Nelson said quote it is
an affront as the senior senator of this
state that an agency head would tell me
that I do not have entrance into a
federally funded facility where the
lives and health children are at stake I
think what they're doing is a cover-up
for the president debbie Wasserman
Schultz says that her office spoke to
the company that runs the center and she
was told she would have no problem
coming in but senator Nelson says that
the Deputy Secretary of HHS told him it
could take two weeks two weeks to get
them access the explanation that they
received from a former head of HHS
administration for Children and Families
is that the policy on paper is you do
have to submit a request two weeks in
advance for a formal examine Ettore
visit is examined Ettore even a word
formal visit to observe or examine but
that in situations of heightened concern
or where there's a particular impetus to
demonstrate or to confirm whether
conditions are actually even acceptable
that the department of homeland sub
Health and Human Services can and should
act quickly period they have the full
ability to say we're gonna just skip the
two-week thing the only reason you
enforce the two-week thing is if you
want to keep people out and you know
these people are right these are members
of the United States Congress I mean
they have every right to go in there I
thought Republicans under Obama anyway
we're all about congressional oversight
apparently not anymore
and transparency and in short they are
now hiding behind a vague protocol where
they have both the full authority and
ability to get people into the facility
if they
want to not showing people what's going
on creates more speculation you keep
people out if the reality is worse than
what people might imagine and I'm
reminded of Donald Trump's taxes the
amount of chaos that was caused by
Donald Trump not releasing his tax
returns during the campaign would only
have been worth it if Trump calculated
that the complaints over him not
releasing the tax returns are better
than what would happen if Trump actually
released the tax returns and I started
thinking as I read this that the reason
you keep people out is if you'd prefer
they guess as to what's going on then
actually have them see what's going on
there there are probably entire areas
where we have no idea what this
administration is hiding from us and
what I mean is we know that the number
of children being detained in these
internment camps is way up under Trump
we know the camps exist we just aren't
sure exactly what the conditions are
what about all of the other stuff that
we have no idea whatsoever that the
Trump administration is even doing and
we don't even know that they're hiding
because we aren't sure where to look
what they admit to is already horrifying
I'm scared of what there what else there
is to find that we don't even have the
slightest clue about yet send me your
thoughts you can discuss this with us on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t quick newly shortened
commercial break and much more after
this